[Music]
think you know your favorite comedies
think again these are the funniest
moments that ever ended up on a cutting
room floor Adam McCay directed and
co-wrote the 2008 comedy film Step
Brothers which has gone on to find a
place among the funniest movies of all
time the plot follows two middleaged men
Brennan and Dale who still live at home
with their parents the pair are forced
to live together and mature as adults
when their mother and father begin
dating and eventually marry step
brother's best eled scene was intended
to come late in the movie just before
Brennan's ultimate Redemption
featuring The always hilarious Rob rle
as Randy the scene demonstrates The
Bullying Brennan has to put up with at
Derek's helicopter leasing firm where he
now works you wake up in the middle of
the night someone's laying next to you
spooning with you chances are it's going
to be me I hope that doesn't happen
despite having some great lines it is
understandable why it was cut given that
Step Brothers already contains a similar
sequence that is far more essential to
the plot in many ways 1995's Tommy Boy
features comedian and actor Chris Farley
at his very best directed by Peter
seagel the movie sees Farley portray the
dimwitted but friendly Thomas Callahan
III who takes over the family business
after the sudden death of his father
teaming up with the anxious and
contemptuous Richard his father's former
assistant Tommy travels across the US to
find new clients to keep the company in
business the SNL alumnist was easily one
of the funniest people on the planet
when he took the lead role in Tommy Boy
and he is undoubtedly best remembered
for the perfectly timed PRP Falls that
made up so much of his physical comedy
Tommy boyy already contained several
great examples of this but one deleted
scene in which he runs across a parking
lot makes a perfect demonstration of his
comic Talent what do you get when you
throw two of the world's best comedic
actors together and add a little golf
for flavor hint the answer certainly
isn't Happy Gilmore Chevy Chase and Bill
Murray had a notable spat in the late
1970s when Chase returned to Saturday
night life an affair that ultimately
ended up in the pair coming to blows on
the show set by 1980 however the pair
had reconciled enough to work together
on Kad Shack a comedy Masterpiece that
follows a young caddy who becomes
embroiled in a feud at the prestigious
golf club where he works unfortunately
Chase and Murray don't interact with
each other much throughout the film but
what does exist is pretty much God need
proof take a look at this deleted scene
in which the bizarre groundskeeper
attempts to give Chase's character some
tips on improving his golf skills see
I'm easy now and I'm back real slow
see well that's I think it's going to be
pretty long it seems like Ro Ferrell
could hardly put a foot wrong when it
came to comedies in the 2000s he starred
in all kinds of Smash Hits from Blades
of Glory to elf to Anchor Man and more
arriving smack bang in the middle of his
most successful period was Talladega
Knights The Ballad of Ricky Bobby a
sports comedy that sees feral portraying
NASCAR racing driver Ricky Bobby
alongside his teammate who is played by
John C Riley Talladega Knights proved a
financial and critical succcess thanks
to no small part are some outstanding
comic moments from Ferell one deleted
scene cesa down on his L driver
attempting to rebuild his his life and
find something new to do at least that's
what he tries to convince his mother son
you've done many things in your life to
make me proud farting in a complete
sentence in one of them Jud appow has
been responsible for some of the best
comedies of the last two decades the
director and writer was a creative force
behind the likes of The 40-Year-Old
Virgin Knocked Up and train wreck in
2012 appal released this is 40 a
followup to KN up that sees Pete and
Debbie attempting to come to terms with
middle age or managing their incre inly
turbulent relationship in one deleted
scene Jason seagull and Chris OD Doubt's
characters Tred their absolute hardest
to flirt with a younger woman played by
Megan Fox James gandia is sort of a sexy
violent kind of dangerous quality about
him it's not just the 4 some things that
come off poorly though as Fox's
character insists on knowing the guy's
star signs to determine how compatible
they would be as a couple mean girls
arrived at a time when Lindsay loham was
at the height of her Fame and still very
much in demand by Hollywood the 2,000 4
comedy was directed by Mark Waters and
co-written by Tina Fay Mel's liely
focuses on the social hierarchy of high
schools and how bullying and clicks can
dominate life for students making it
challenging to be themselves and express
any individuality much of the humor
comes from the interactions between the
students but there are also some
entertaining scenes featuring the
youngsters with their parents take one
deleted scene for example which features
a brief but hilarious argument between
Katie and her parents featuring a
hilarious subtext translation these are
on sale
these are
wellmade those are
hideous I don't think those are
appropriate in 2003 director John favro
teamed up with Will Ferrell for Elf a
Christmas comedy that has since become a
classic of the holiday season Ferrell
plays buddy a human orphan accidentally
taken back to the North Pole and adopted
by the elves after becoming trapped in
Santa's Toy sack feeling increasingly
out of place among the elves an older
buddy returns to New York City to search
for his biological father along the way
he discovers more about himself while
also helping to redeem his dad who
transforms from a selfish jerk into a
loving father the early stages of Elf
deal with Buddy Coming to Terms of the
fact that he doesn't quite fit him with
the elf kind due to his larger size one
deleted scene shows buddy participating
in a hockey game in which he overpowers
every elf around him it's fairly
understandable that this one was removed
of course the movie takes considerable
pains elsewhere to demonstrate that
Buddy isn't an ordinary elf Deadpool
Stars Ryan Reynolds as a notorious
anti-hero who sets out to Hunts the evil
scientists tortured him and gave him his
unique powers at the same time Wade
Wilson strives to find the courage to
reconnect with his girlfriend Vanessa
Wade's pining over Vanessa is the
subject of this deleted scene in which
Deadpool follows his love interest from
a distance but never quite manages to
get close enough to reveal himself it's
a seemingly tender moments that shows
the softer side of Deadpool that is
until he's hit by a truck and wakes up
in the morog IR Man 3 is not going to go
down as one of the most popular MCU
installments but that certainly doesn't
make it a bad movie Robert Downey Junior
returns to his iconic role as Tony Stark
with the titular hero facing numerous
struggles in his personal life that are
exacerbated by a wave of attacks led by
the mysterious Mandarin all of this
means that Iron Man 3 isn't exactly
teaming with jokes and it doesn't have
quite as much space for comedy as some
other MCU installments that may well be
why this scene was cut from the film in
which Trevor Slattery performs accents
to try and get himself out of a sticky
situation with Iron Man and War Machine
starky dead the body is here okay that's
good work you stay on the talent you
don't let him out of your sight copy
that that's me I'm the talent the
impersonation ultimately works with
alternate endings to the scene adding to
the hilarity can you do uh
British well I am British although Adam
Sandler has had mixed results when it
comes to his more recent comedy projects
He has very much proved that he has what
it takes as a dramatic performer one of
Sandler's earliest serious roles came in
Punch Drunk Love a 2002 film that was
not a financial success but brought
Sandler widespread Acclaim he portrays
Barry eag skin a socially awkward
executive Who falls in love and finds
his Dell life suddenly transformed due
to a series of unexpected events the
primary antagonist in Punch Drunk Love
is Dean Trumble the owner of the
mattress store that sandless character
visits a deleted commercial for the
store sees Trumble advertising his
business before jumping off a roof onto
some mattresses however things don't go
as plann D and D mattress has queen
mattress sets for $99 and King sets for
$19 W combines the talents of Amy
Schumer Jud appow and Bill haer for a
light-hearted romantic comedy Schumer
starts as a promiscuous independent
writer who has sworn off monogamy her
whole life yet her feelings start to
shift when she meets a sports doctor
played by hater who makes her reconsider
her whole life philosophy that doesn't
come easy though with the right of
finding it difficult to completely
change her ways after Decades of heavy
drinking and late nights the movie's
alterate ending show Schumer holding a
baby before quickly revealing that it
isn't hers but rather her sister's she
then admits she loves being an aunt the
sentimentality of the moment proves to
be too much though and the character
quickly shows that she hasn't fully
moved on from her former lifestyle as
she discusses grabbing a drink or four
there should never have been any doubt
that Planes Trains and Automobiles would
go down as a comedy classic after all
the 1987 film not only Stars comic
Giants Steve Martin and John Candy but
was also written and directed by John
Hughes the man behinds The Breakfast
Club and Ferris bu's day off a
Thanksgiving Staple in the US the film
follows Neil Page a tightly wound
executive who is trying to get home for
the holidays after a freak storm diverts
his plane along the way he meets Dell
Griffith and the two soon Clash due to
their very different personalities one
of the movie's many deleted scenes sees
Dell ordering and preparing his food on
board a plane revealing his meticulous
methods toward ensuring he gets the best
meal possible on every Airline an
American I'll have their kosher plate
Little slice of salami some roast beef
some turkey dark Ry RB very nice few
actors can make eating food on a plane
entertaining but candy manages to do
just that throwing some great gags into
the mix as well the New Zealand comedy
horror what we do in the shadows proved
to be so successful that it launched an
entire franchise Jermaine Clement and
Tao ITI jointly took on writing and
directing duties for the 2014 release
which CHS the lives of several vampires
living in the present day in New
Zealand's Capital City Wellington when a
new face joins the ranks of the undead
the group faces fresh challenges as they
struggle to fully cope with Modern Life
a cute deleted scene from the movie
movie shows fiago and Deacon discussing
the pottery Creations they've been
working on albe it with little success
it's like a boat filled with some slugs
later the two discuss their romantic
lives and the age difference between
viago and his love interest you know
like she's like
96 and I'm like 3177 you know people are
going to talk Rob riner's 1984
mockumentary This Is Spinal Tap is a
Bonafide cult class classic Christopher
Guest Michael mcken and Harry Shir Stars
the three charter members of a fictional
British heavy metal band who are
followed by a documentary crew that
captures the trials and tribulations of
the group having popularized a
mockumentary genre This Is Spinal Tap is
filled with iconic moments that have
since become part of Pop Culture history
one scene that didn't make it into the
Final Cut and engage in an in-depth
discussion about what Apes actually eat
it is exactly as bizarre as it sounds
with a group seemingly concluding that
apes and monkeys are primarily bre
eaters they're bread eaters mainly they
go for you know any kind of bread is and
yet it's and yet they've developed as a
race they've developed no baking skills
one band member even reveals that some
gorillas can talk although none of them
are capable of swearing for some unknown
reason here's later Michael mcken
admitted on X formerly known as Twitter
that he hadn't actually seen this
particular deleted scene from spinal tap
an early film in Jim car's career dumb
and dummer stands as a comedy classic
that helped make the comic actor a
household name the film follows Lloyd
Christmas and Harry Dunn as they set out
to return a lost suitcase inadvertently
becoming involved in a kidnapping plot
involving a dangerous criminal group kri
was certainly committed to making sure
Lloyd remained as dumb as can be leading
to a lot of hilarious moments in this
laugh a minute movie throughout the film
Lloyd and Harry come into conflict with
a trucker called Cass violent and quick
to anger Cass swears revenge against the
pair after they trick him into paying
for their food at a diner they later
encountered a truck driver at a gas
station with Seabass telling Lloyd that
he plans to attack and kill him luckily
Harry interrupts this genuinely Haring
moment to save the
[Music]
day in many ways scary movie launched an
entire genre of spoof ranging from
subsequent parodies of horror films to
the likes of Disaster Movie and Epic
movie a product of the Wayan's Brothers
with various members of the family
directing writing and starring in the
film scary movie became a franchise that
later spawned for sequels the movie
follows a group of teenagers were hunted
by a vicious killer wearing a Ghost Face
Mask the opening scene of scary movie
closely resembles the early moments of
scream in which Silla phones a young
woman and begins to threaten her the
scary movie version is decidedly goofier
however a short 30-second clip that was
removed from the sequel CES a murderer
slowly chased down Drew until it is
revealed that she is actually running on
a treadmill before Andy Samberg became a
worldwide star for his leading role in
Brooklyn 99 the SNL alumni stared in
several comedies throughout the late
2000s and early 2010s in hot rod Samberg
takes on the role of an aspiring stunt
man named Rod who is frequently berated
and taunted by his stepfather Frank when
Frank Falls ill Rod plans his biggest
stunt ever to raise enough money to pay
for his medical care one of the movies
deleted scenes depicts Rod recreating a
famous stunt in his bedroom using toys
and a pool table before the action takes
an extreme turn as a dinosaur attacks
his stepfather the 2018 film solo a Star
Wars story follows a young Khan solo as
he embarks on a major Heist meets
chewbaca and Lando kiz and acquires the
Millennium Falcon solo isn't a comedy
per se yet the film still features
several funny moments that add some
levity to the proceedings the entire
movie May well have been even more
light-hearted if one deleted scene had
stayed in which shows Han and Chewbacca
having a snowball fight as they Traverse
a winry
planet 1994 was very much the year that
Jim Cary became a worldwide superstar
having taken on lead roles in The Mask
Dum and dummer and of course Ace Ted
detective in this movie Carrie plays an
unconventional animal expert t with
tracking down the missing mascot of the
Miami Dolphins previously only available
on home releases of the movie This
deleted scene was intended for the early
part of the movie when Ace begins to
investigate The Disappearance of the
dolphin known as snowflake with
reporters asking to get a look at the
mascot Ace pretends to be a German
animal trainer to throw off suspicion
that snowflake is missing why do you
care about the dolphin do you know him
does he call you at home do you have a
do
P long before the MCU hit its stride Sam
ry's Spider-Man trilogy brought the
adventures of Peter Parker to the big
screen in a liveaction adaptation of the
comic book web Slinger the sequel which
hit Cinema screens in 2004 find
Spider-Man facing Dr Octopus as the
villain seeks revenge against him after
the death of his wife one of the
standout performances in Remy's Trilogy
is JK Simmons portrayal of the daily
bugles editor-in Chief J Jonah Jameson
harboring the truly intense hatred of
Spider-Man Jameson does everything he
can to discredit the young hero yet he
also provides some of the best moments
of comic relief a great example of that
comes in one of the movie's deleted
scenes in which Jameson puts on the
Spider-Man costume and pretends to be
the superhero in front of his bemused
employees there have been many James
Bond spoofs over the years but none have
been quite as successful as the Austin
Powers franchise the first installment
Austin Powers international Man of
Mystery arrived in 1997 establishing the
formula that was to follow in two
further sequels Mike Meers stars as a
aonomus British secret agent and his
arch nemesis Dr Evil as they battled
through time and struggle to adapt to
modern day sensibilities a recurring
joke in the awers franchise focuses on
henchmen failing to escape from danger
no matter how easy it might be this
began in the first film with a
steamroller flattening a helpless guard
despite moving at a snail's pace a
follow-up scene to this sequence which
was removed from most versions of the
movie examines the effects of the
guard's death on his
family people never think how things
affect the family of a henchman stop War
episode 3 Revenge of the Sith is the
third and final entry in the Star Wars
prequel trilogy depicting Anakin
Skywalker's transformation into Darth
Vader and the destruction of the Jedi
Order set drawing the closing stages of
the Clone Wars the film Chronicles of
Galactic Republic's continuing war
against the separatists who are under
the secret control of the Sith it isn't
exactly the Star Wars entry in which
you'd expect to find many jokes or
physical comedy that's for sure but it's
there as Anakin and Obi-Wan Kenobi hunt
down General Grievous on his Starship
they faced numerous obstacles in one
deleted scene this includes getting lost
and needing help from R2-D2 while
discussing what they should do Anakin
suddenly begins speaking in Droid I'm
pretty sure that beep is down I sense
Count Dooku is above us oh yes yes yes
you're right beep is up of course it's
entirely possible that this is an
intentionally funny rather than an
outright joke it certainly wouldn't be
the first time that's happened in a Star
Wars
movie